alles war sie aufgestanden
kann ich mit meinen kleinen haus in
verwandt oder verheiratet
sie ist meine freundin sie schwanger
dann können sie auch der beifahrersitz
rossi lotte wollte sie mit den kräften
die erste rate kann angewiesen werden
den vertrag habe ich bereits gefasst
alex events in der richtige partner für
dieses projekt sehr kooperativ und
zuverlässig wäre eine kalkulation
erstellt und dann wirst du sie das 25
euro pro person nicht reichen
solange wir nicht dein kokolores
anbieten kommen wir damit hin
am morgen gibt es frisches obst zum
beispiel auf spießen kokolores
hallo hallo manchmal kann ich will ich
tun
eine apfelschorle hatte wenn du dich
noch mal so an johann machst denn wer
legte joe erzielen ist klar klar 20
gipfel und ziele ich möchte bei ihnen
arbeiten als kellnerin
zwei bis dreimal wöchentlich halbe tage
mindestlohn 8 euro 50
und nicht jedes wochenende dann schon
mal in ein restaurant serviert kilogramm
ja nein aber ich bin lernfähig und
flexibel
außerdem kann ich ganz gut backen sieht
sie den versuch endet mit dem mädchen
noch ich muss dir was sagen welche wird
ist denn lothar sie nicht im krankenhaus
ich musste vorzunehmen
was ist passiert ich weiß nicht sie
zusammengebrochen
ich begleite dich du kannst hier
übernehmen du kannst direkt anfangen
hallo ich wollte gerne was bestellen
wollen sind die beiden slaughter ins
krankenhaus
lothar schäfer ja kennen sie und am
nachmittag können wir denn das shooting
für 16 und der zweiten location ansätzen
willst dir recht ist francisco das kommt
aufs wetter an alex alles klappt wird
nein gelungenen vormittag
ich werde die probeaufnahmen gefallen
hey warum sagst du nicht locker sie
hatte einen unfall
warum wurde doch ganz krankenhaus
gelaufen krankenhaus was ist passiert
da kann immer jemand sagen was hier los
ist gestürzt und hat sich den kopf am
schreibtisch geschlossen ins büro ins
krankenhaus gefahren
nein sie war nicht ich hab schon auf dem
weg hin auch nicht erreicht wo ist da
nix keine ahnung sie ist weg